how often do i stream
not very often
this is the second time though within
the past few days
streamed on monday
thursday now
said harsh
uh
harshana
we've played three games
don't recall the time control
pretty sure it wasn't rapid
all right
d4
c4 and we'll see what we get
an aggressive player
benco benko nobenko
what about grunfeld
that's an indication of an aggressive
player we have a grunfeld
all right we're going to go with knight
f3
and a line that i don't have much
experience with but
try this queen b3
most common move i've played
on this move 5 is bishop to g5
c6
not
normally it's the capture
so i'm just kind of scanning
to see you know what's the difference
here
should i play play bishop to f4 or
is everything just cool with e3 and then
i'm in a spot to recapture conveniently
if they they chop on c4
i'm going to take this timeout to go
ahead and
throw the bishop on f4
not g5 here um
i referenced g5 just a little bit ago
i like the bishop on f4
h6 is usually desirable move
with the fiend kiddo
so some pressure against
the queen offering a queen exchange
this is the first move that crossed my
mind i don't think i'm uh
i don't think i want to do that i want
to keep some pressure here
so let's simply go with e3
and i definitely don't want to take
their queen
i think e3 is
one of the better moves
what to do where will this guy go we
still don't know
uh
bishop to d3
yeah
i'm gonna go with d3 with the following
reasoning
i don't want to see this knight move to
the center so easily because if he gets
here he's black has helped in two ways
the knight
and the bishop c
see the world a little bit better
that move
all right definitely heating up
creating more tension on c4
c5 queen takes pawn takes
knight
d7b4a6 i'm not in time to get that move
in
however
i think i'm still gonna go with it
because i like the control i have over
e5 this counter strike of e5 is a bit
more difficult to get in with the bishop
on e6
and i could still look forward i think
to this kind of maneuver where i put
pressure on b7 in that resulting
structure
do i have an alternative here i really
don't want to capture and allow this and
this square to open up i could i could
go for that
um
well let's let's try this structure
yeah let's go for this one
expecting them to take my queen they
really don't have much choice because
there isn't a good way to move the queen
and defend b7 i have c6
excuse me i have c7 under my control
so the queens are gonzo
h6 feels a little slow
um
actually now
i i thought that i thought the main
approach for black should have been to
get these uh quick moves in so that i
can't un-double my b-pawns so now i'm
leaning much more towards this expansion
this also crosses my mind i'm trying to
eliminate my dark square bishop
let's start with this i may i may still
abandon this plan in favor of securing
my dark square bishop
so this is the this is the big moment i
have to really
focus on
i'm thinking of these two moves secure
my dark square bishop or be assured i
undouble my b pawns which one is better
i don't know
um
i'm leaning more towards this actually
b5 knight h5
and then the bishop move like the
bishop's gonna move i want i want to
make sure this is under control i'm
gonna opt for h3
yeah i'm opting for h3 right now i'm i'm
preventing their pawn break i'm giving
more weight to stopping their e5 move
and
i'm making life i think a bit more
difficult
for this guy too
okay so they stop b5
suppose i try and squeeze this guy with
g4
don't even allow him to exchange himself
off for my you know this is the bad guy
that's my good guy
maybe i play on the king side some
grab some space here i'm going to go for
that
so i have space on the queen side
maybe looking for space on the king side
and who knows maybe i hop into the
center at some point
okay
hmm
i guess i'll go back one i don't see a
reason to go here
the i may want to keep open the option
of h4 now there's a hook
their king could maybe
be exposed some
where where is the break going to come
sacrifices on g4 aren't concerning me
clock is concerning me some okay prep
work for this maybe knight g5 knight g5
knight knight c6 is maybe nearby
what can i be doing in the meantime
maybe i can look forward to
f4
let's go for this i'm hinting at not
only this but f4
no i don't know about that because this
would be weakened this is a pretty
serious threat though
okay let's let's be consistent let's
follow through with this knight putting
pressure on b7 that has to grab my
opponent's attention some
uh let's go in for it now
[Music]
or improve mic
you know let's go infer right now
okay there
be careful here be careful
a lot of maneuvering this is this has
cost
me a lot of time here
i'm prepared to meet this with this and
then a capture i'm getting my knight out
of this in between stuff where the pawn
goes into pac-man mode
if i just made a rook move and then e5
and then took here they could take here
maybe beyond my knight okay so right now
am i not winning a pawn i take on g6
giving up a big bishop but i am getting
a pawn
they could put their knight on e4 i
should be able to deal with that i'm
going to take the knight
and then take here
just want a pawn but they have the
bishop pair
i don't know how great my knight is my
knight is actually controlling these two
is it not
got to go faster i'm down three minutes
okay some more some more control
maybe put my knife back on this square
are this square
make a decision and fast all right let's
start with this
yeah knight on c3
maybe i keep my bishop right there if
it's challenge knight d7 maybe maybe i
play f4
here this check i could take because a
bishop i always think i have a follow-up
fork i have to be careful of knight e4
unleashing this in a this attack against
e5 maybe winning the pawn back
leaning more towards king e2 okay so
that move
suppose i chop here first yeah i think
that's correct
and next
i'm gonna take here
i could undouble my pawns knight takes
pawn takes i have a c4 break
that would be wonderful if i get my
knight into d5
i might be close to getting that in even
there's still
this this knight is super pesky okay so
i have options
could take this pawn
but i think it's simplest to go ahead
and take here build my center
and then look for this break
i don't even know if i want that let's
go here
f3 king f2
rookie 1 and e4
okay
that they're finding it a convenient
configuration here
i still keep my knight there
yep
yeah
that's
good i want to keep control over f5
thinking i i should have had my king on
g3
i may want to put my king on a light
square so i could do some capture here
not end up in a pin
down about two minutes now
it's three earlier okay
okay now maybe i go for c4
okay
let's chop first
where does my night belong
hmm
and do something a little weird
i should have thought more about that
last move
this was my idea
is that a mouselet
okay let's make sure i
rescue my knight
this was my idea to get this break in
i have lost control
however i've gained it back
now i should be winning this server this
pawn survives that was too
i pulled the trigger too fast on that
one
three connected passers potentially if
they if they go here i can't take
okay yeah we're going with the three
connected passers this is
should be easily winning time-wise
objectively i know it's a win but time
don't
forget about the time
yeah i lost control i i shouldn't have
really gone for c6 so fast i i lucked
out to have this
enormous position where the pawns live
this was not uh
i didn't plan that
okay let's sidestep that right we don't
want that happening
we don't want to go into any pins
so i just want one rook off and then the
king here and everything is wonderful
even if i lose this even if they get a
passer there's going to be much too slow
may not even need a rook in some
variations if these guys get here and
the king is out of play
okay so now king up like this there is
no more pin
let's improve the king
i'm ready to contest any open file i
could have already got to the seventh
rank
but i just want to move my pawnees
e5 nearby
push the past pawns okay the setting
tricks up again
maybe i could set up a trick of my own
why not i can afford that
so you chop here i give a check i give a
check take a rook and then take a rook
or chop check here and i'm unpinned and
i could take a rook again
maybe even there's mates actually
here check
here rook f6 is mate
so chop
check here would be forced
check chop chop
a lot of chops could have also done this
and avoided any pins
but who can
complain about these monsters on the
only open files
all right see how it finishes
under two
only down a minute
okay
bonds are rolling
and if the rook goes back it's mate with
that
okay swiped upon
the width check
and
let's
let's let's let's
the king can't move now
one two three
can't do much about it i just ignore
that move
we're going in for the kill
i don't want to allow any captures in
some
sixth rank to open up and
challenge my king on e6
that's um kind of the quick thought i
had before
playing here
okay
and where is the mate
all right
you